Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History, and we are in the heart of Amsterdam, aren't we, Tom? Now, if you didn't hear our last episode, we are exploring the history of Amsterdam with WISE. Now, Tom, as you will know, WISE is the international account that is built to save you money around the world. You love that, don't you, Tom? 150 countries, 40 currencies, and just one account. And as you are always saying to me, I mean, God almighty, if I had a pound to pay the number of times you've said this to me, with WISE, you can spend like a local. And Dominic, more importantly,
感谢收听《历史的 rest》节目。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听权限以及我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你好，欢迎收听《历史的 rest》，我们现在正处于阿姆斯特丹的市中心，对吧，汤姆？如果你没有听上一期节目，我们正在与 WISE 一起探索阿姆斯特丹的历史。汤姆，正如你所知，WISE 是一款旨在为您在世界各地省钱的国际账户。你很喜欢这个，对吧，汤姆？150个国家，40种货币，只需一个账户。正如你经常对我说的那样，天哪，如果我能为你说这话的次数付一英镑的话，有了 WISE，你就能像当地人一样消费。更重要的是，多米尼克，
you could spend like a Dutch capitalist in the golden age of amsterdam so dominic uh the end of the last episode we were talking about um amsterdam as simultaneously this inward looking and this outward looking city yeah so this concern with the domestic with the interior kind of privacy while at the same time amsterdam is really the kind of the great smithy of what will become European globalization. Expanding trade networks, all the wealth and goods and commodities of the world coming to Amsterdam. So the people here are, certainly the elites, are fabulously rich.
你可以在阿姆斯特丹的黄金时代像一个荷兰资本家一样消费。所以多米尼克，嗯，在上一集的末尾，我们讨论了阿姆斯特丹这座城市既具有向内看的特质，又具有向外看的特质，是吗？对，这种对家庭内部、私人空间的关注，与此同时，阿姆斯特丹真正成为了未来欧洲全球化的大熔炉。贸易网络不断扩大，世界上所有的财富、货物和商品都涌向阿姆斯特丹。因此，这里的人们，尤其是精英阶层，极其富有。
So Amsterdam is absolutely a boom town. This is the 17th century 17th century but the dutch republic is still at war you know the the spanish are still out there yeah and so the old center of amsterdam is is kind of girded around by this canal the single and by a wall and basically you know you're not encouraged to build out beyond that but people ignore that they're camping out on what remains basically a bog yeah um the amstel literally means you know boggy land next to a river and the land beyond the old town hasn't yet been drained but amsterdam is is becoming so rich and it's becoming so full that over the course of the 17th century, people decide this
所以阿姆斯特丹绝对是一个蓬勃发展的城市。这是17世纪，17世纪，但荷兰共和国仍在打仗，你知道，西班牙人依然在虎视眈眈，对吧。因此，阿姆斯特丹的老城区周围环绕着辛格运河和一道城墙，基本上，你知道的，人们不鼓励在城墙之外进行建设，但人们无视这一点，他们在基本上仍然是沼泽的地方安营扎寨，对吧，嗯，阿姆斯特丹（Amstel）这个词字面意思就是指河边的沼泽地，老城区以外的土地尚未被排干，但阿姆斯特丹变得如此富有，人口如此拥挤，以至于在17世纪的进程中，人们决定这样做
is insane. We need to expand. So they start to move beyond the single, this canal that surrounds the old town. And they build what are probably the iconic image of Amsterdam in people's imagination. If they kind of think of Amsterdam, they will think of these three great ring canals that were built in the 17th century. So the Herrengracht, so that's the canal for gentlemen. The gentleman's canal. The Kaiser's gracht, the emperor's canal, and the Prinzengracht, the prince's canal. And we are standing on the Herrengracht,
太疯狂了。我们需要扩张。于是他们开始越过辛格运河，即环绕老城区的这条运河，向外拓展。他们建造了人们想象中最具阿姆斯特丹标志性的景观。如果人们想到阿姆斯特丹，他们就会想到在17世纪建造的三条宏伟的环形运河。也就是绅士运河（Herengracht）——那是绅士们的运河，绅士运河；国王运河（Kaiser's gracht），皇帝的运河；以及王子运河（Prinzengracht），王子的运河。我们现在正站在绅士运河上，
which is the most exclusive of those three canals. And just to compete with the traffic and to paint a picture for those three canals and just to um compete with the traffic and to paint a picture for those people who haven't been to amsterdam forget about the traffic noise it's an idyllic scene these tremendously impressive kind of merchants townhouses along the sides of the canal um bicycles and all that yeah and where we're standing is called the golden bend so it's the the most prestigious stretch of the most prestigious canal. Yeah. And the amazing thing about these three canals, that they look perfect.
这是三条运河中最独具一格、最高档的一条。为了配合交通情况，为那些没去过阿姆斯特丹的人描绘一幅画面，再为了配合交通情况并为那些没去过阿姆斯特丹的人描绘一幅画面，抛开交通噪音不谈，这是一幅田园诗般的场景，运河两旁是一排排极其壮观的商人联排别墅，还有自行车等等，对吧。我们站的地方被称为“黄金湾”（Golden Bend），它是最高档运河中最负盛名的一段。对。这三条运河最神奇的地方在于，它们看起来完美无缺。
And people have always thought, historians of the development of Amsterdam, have always traditionally thought that there is a kind of a master plan. Yeah. But it turns out actually there probably wasn't't that it was built in three separate stages which makes the site kind of the sense of coherence the um the controlled sense of beauty all the more extraordinary i mean it's one of the the great urban panoramas of europe and the world i would say and what makes it all the more extraordinary is as i say the effort of construction because all these stunning houses the the roads, all the infrastructure is built on the marshiest terrain imaginable. And so the reason that there are canals,
人们一直认为，阿姆斯特丹发展的历史学家们传统上一直认为这里有一种总体规划。对。但事实证明，实际上可能并没有，它是分三个不同阶段建造的，这使得这个地方的连贯感、可控的美感更加非凡。我的意思是，它是欧洲乃至全世界最伟大的城市全景之一，我想这么说。让这一切更加非凡的是，正如我所说，建设所付出的努力，因为所有这些令人惊叹的房屋、道路、所有的基础设施都是建立在可以想象得到的、最泥泞的沼泽地形之上。所以这里有运河的原因是，
these have to be kind of dredged out. The mud has to be piled up on the banks, has to be mixed with sand and with gravel. Roads have to be laid down with brick. And if you're going to build houses, then you need to kind of drive down wood, great piles of wood. So logs that are sourced from Scandinavia. And they have to be jammed down kind of 50, 60 feet into the peat, into the sand, into the clay. And those logs are still there to this day because they've been covered over by water. So the wood has been preserved. And it was such an effort to build these. But one of the reasons why these houses are very high, kind of five, six stories,
这些运河必须经过疏浚。泥土必须堆积在河岸上，必须与沙子和砾石混合。道路必须用砖块铺设。如果你要盖房子，那么你需要往下打木桩，大量的木桩。也就是取材自斯堪的纳维亚的圆木。它们必须被强行打入泥炭、沙子和黏土中50到60英尺深。那些圆木至今仍然留在那里，因为它们被水覆盖着。所以木头得到了保存。建造这些房子需要付出巨大的努力。但这些房子建得很高（大约五六层）的原因之一是，
is that basically if you've gone to all the expense and effort of driving down these kind of piles to support the houses on, you might as well build it high. And so throughout the 17th century, it's the golden age. It's the age of Rembrandt. It's the age of kind of scientific inquiry. And we look around and this is a beautiful, beautiful urban cityscape. But throughout the 17th century, this was a massive, massive building site. I mean, ongoing for decades and decades and decades. One of the ways in which you can measure what the impact was of this on people who lived in Amsterdam is to look at the paintings and the drawings of Rembrandt, his greatest artist, the artist who moved and lived here for most of his life. And what you will find is that he doesn't actually paint or draw anything of what is going on with this new development. So again and again, if he's making sketches of the cityscapecape he will do views towards the old city or towards
基本上，如果你已经花了所有的精力和资金来打下这些支撑房子的木桩，你不如把它建得高一些。因此，在整个17世纪，这是黄金时代。这是伦勃朗的时代。这是科学探索的时代。我们环顾四周，这是一幅美丽至极的城市风景画。但在整个17世纪，这是一个规模庞大、极其宏大的建筑工地。持续了数十年之久。你可以通过观察伦勃朗（他的最伟大艺术家，在这里生活了大部分时间的艺术家）的绘画和素描，来衡量这对生活在阿姆斯特丹的人们产生了什么影响。你会发现，他实际上并没有画任何关于这个新开发项目的画作或素描。所以一次又一次地，如果他在画城市风景的草图，
the open fields he will not sketch what is being developed so almost like he's literally turned his back on this new i suppose the equivalent of the megalopolises of uh 21st century china temples to capitalism absolutely so there's a sense that um that rembrandt in his attitude to this new architecture is a bit of a King Charles III. Right. He's not in favor of it. But clearly, if you're a massive, high-spending capitalist with lots of cash, you're really into it. And so the house that we're looking at at the moment
他会画向旧城区或开阔田野的景象，他不会勾勒正在开发的东西。所以几乎就像他实际上背对了这个新的——我想这就相当于21世纪中国的特大城市，资本主义的圣殿，绝对如此。所以有一种感觉，伦勃朗对这种新建筑的态度有点像查尔斯三世国王。没错。他并不赞成。但显然，如果你是一个拥有大量现金的大型、高消费的资本主义者，你真的很喜欢它。所以我们目前看到的这座房子
is one of the grandest, most impressive, most beautiful houses on the entire stretch of the Herringbrack. And this is the House van de Graaf. So this is the mayor of Amsterdam's house. Andries, what's his name? Andries de Graaf. Yeah. Yes.
是绅士运河沿岸最宏伟、最壮观、最美丽的房子之一。这就是范德格拉夫府（House van de Graaf）。所以这是阿姆斯特丹市长的房子。安德里斯，他叫什么名字？安德里斯·德·格拉夫（Andries de Graaf）。对。是的。
He was a mayor of the city. He was one of its richest men. And he's one of two brothers who basically run Amsterdam as a Republican form of government throughout its golden age. So Tom, just as we start talking about the politics, let's move away from the man assembling an air conditioning unit.
他是该市的市长。他是最富有的人之一。在整个黄金时代，他和另一个兄弟以共和政体形式共同管理着阿姆斯特丹。所以汤姆，在我们开始谈论政治的时候，让我们离开那个正在组装空调机的家伙。
It's always the way, isn't it? Right by where we're talking. It's always the way. So at this point, the Netherlands is the Dutch Republic. It is not a monarchy. Am I right? Right. So basically, there are two kind of political factions
总是这样，不是吗？就在我们谈话的地方旁。总是这样。所以此时，荷兰是荷兰共和国。它不是一个君主国。我没说错吧？没错。所以基本上，有两种政治派别，
in the various provinces that constitute the Dutch Republic. So there's a Republican faction, of which the de Graaf brothers are leaders in Amsterdam. There are also the de Wits in The Hague. And these are kind of the equivalents of grand senators, leaders of what are effectively city states. But over and above that, you have the figure of the Stadtholder, which has become a kind of hereditary post held by the descendants of William the Silent, Willem of Orange, who was the great hero of the Dutch revolt.
分布在组成荷兰共和国的各个省份中。有一个共和派，德·格拉夫兄弟是他们在阿姆斯特丹的领袖。海牙还有德·维特兄弟。这些基本上相当于宏大的参议员、实际上是城邦领袖的人物。但在这一切之上，你拥有执政官（Stadtholder）这一职位，它已经成为一种世袭职位，由沉默者威廉（William the Silent）也就是奥兰治的威廉（Willem of Orange，荷兰起义的伟大英雄）的后代担任。
And so the Stadtholders are, well, I suppose actually dominate the best English translation would be Lord Protector. Very good. You know I love a Lord Protector. Yes, I know you do. So there's a tension there between the claims of the cities and the claims of the Stadtholder. Of the House of Orange. So these tensions come to a head in Amsterdam in 1650, when Willem II, who is the Stadtholder,
所以执政官是——嗯，我想最好的英文翻译应该是“护国公”。非常棒。你知道我喜欢护国公。是的，我知道你喜欢。所以城市的要求和执政官的要求之间存在着一种紧张关系。奥兰治家族的要求。这些紧张关系在1650年的阿姆斯特丹达到顶峰，当时执政官威廉二世，
the Prince of Orange, he comes to Amsterdam and he basically tries to kind of conquer it and suppress the pretensions of the town council town council the de graffs play a blinder they basically say to villum look um we're on your side uh there are people opposed to you on the town council let's get rid of them and they serve up their rivals on the town council get rid of them and then they're able to install this and with enormous stroke of luck that obviously to the digraphs would be the sign of god um villum then then dies of smallpox right and he leaves a very young son villum again they're not very original with their naming who will be the william the third who conquers england in 1688 but he's a very young boy at this point so essentially the digraphs now have a kind of free hand to run the city.
奥兰治亲王，他来到阿姆斯特丹，基本上试图征服它并压制市议会的野心。德·格拉夫兄弟棋高一着。他们基本上对威廉说：“看，嗯，我们站在你这边，市议会上有人反对你，让我们除掉他们吧。”他们把市议会的政敌端出来除掉，然后他们就能够安插这个。伴随着巨大的好运——对德·格拉夫家族来说这显然是上帝的旨意——威廉随后死于天疱疮/天花，对，他留下了一个非常年幼的儿子，也叫威廉（他们的命名很不原创新意），他就是1688年征服英格兰的威廉三世，但他当时还是个非常小的男孩，所以基本上德·格拉夫家族现在有了一种自由裁量权来管理这座城市。
And they do this up until 1672, which the Dutch commemorate as the Rampja, the year of disasters, which is when Louis XIV invades the English, I'm afraid to say,
他们一直这样做到1672年。荷兰人将这一年纪念为“灾难年”（Rampjaar），也就是路易十四入侵，而英国人，恐怕不得不说，
institute a naval blockade. Afraid to say. The de Witt brothers are lynched and, according to some stories, devoured by a hostile mob. Willem III kind of absolutely establishes his authority as Stadtholder. The de Graaffs lose power, but Andries de Graaff doesn't.
发动了海上封锁。恐怕不得不说。德·维特兄弟被林奇私刑处死，根据某些说法，还被愤怒的暴民分食了。威廉三世确立了他作为执政官的绝对权威。德·格拉夫家族失去了权力，但安德里斯·德·格拉夫没有。
I mean, he keeps his life, he keeps his wealth, and he keeps this absolutely splendid house. So we are looking at the house right now, aren't we? There's a bit of scaffolding, but you can see the tremendous coat of arms at the top top which is this sort of swan and it looks like a bit like a mushroom i don't know what it is no it's it's um it's a shovel a shovel okay and the the motto of the graph was um death makes scepters and hoes equal okay so this is idea that you know the um his house is built on the side of this canal which has been dug with ho hose and with shovels and with spades. And he's kind of glorying in that as something that is greater than the monarchical pretensions
我的意思是，他保住了性命，保住了财富，还保住了这座极其豪华的房子。所以我们现在正在看着这座房子，不是吗？有一些脚手架，但你可以看到顶部巨大的家族徽章，它是一种天鹅，有点像蘑菇，我不知道那是什么。不，它是，嗯，它是一把铁铲，一把铲子。好的。德·格拉夫家族的座右铭是“死亡让权杖和锄头平等”。好吧，所以这里的想法是，你知道，他的房子建在这个运河边上，而运河是用锄头、铲子和铁锹挖掘出来的。他以此为傲，认为这比奥兰治家族的君主政体野心更伟大。
of the House of Orange. He also, inside, he had one of the greatest art collections of the age. So we've mentioned Rembrandt. He had Rembrandts in there. Rembrandt painted him, but various other artworks by the great painters of the age. So on one level, it's absolutely sumptuous and splendid. But on the other, bearing in mind that this isn't, you know,
此外，他的室内拥有那个时代最伟大的艺术收藏之一。所以我们提到了伦勃朗。他那里有伦勃朗的作品。伦勃朗画过他，还有那个时代伟大画家的其他各种艺术品。所以从某个层面来看，它是绝对奢华和壮丽的。但从另一方面来看，考虑到这不是，你知道的，
he's not just one of the richest men in Amsterdam. He's one of the richest men in the world. He is a plutocrat on a scale of a kind of Jeff Bezos or Mark Zuckerberg. It's actually pretty modest. Yeah. So that is actually the most striking thing about this, I think. So there are working class districts being built at the same time. There's a place called Jordan, which is kind of beyond the Prinzengracht, which is the canal for merchants. It's a lovely area, actually, the Jordan now.
他不仅仅是阿姆斯特丹最富有的人之一。他是世界上最富有的人之一。他是杰夫·贝佐斯或马克·扎克伯格级别的大财阀。实际上这相当朴素。是的。所以这实际上是最引人注目的地方，我认为。同时，工人阶级区也在建设中。有一个叫约达安（Jordaan）的地方，它有点超出王子运河的范围，王子运河是商人们的运河。现在约达安是个很可爱的地方，其实。
Yeah, it is. But I think one of the striking things about this is that the streets that kind of join the canals are actually actually they were built as much more working class areas so it's exclusive but it's not completely exclusive right um it's not a kind of upper class ghetto right and again i think that that is expressive of this dutch sense of kind of civic community that is a contrast with the kind of grandiose pomposity of architecture particularly in france right absolutist monarchy catholic monarchy of louis the 14th there must be a self-consciously deliberate political contrast the dutch see themselves as protestants as as you said civic as modest yeah
是的，确实如此。但我认为其中一个显著特点是，连接运河的街道实际上，它们在很大程度上被建成了更多工人阶级的区域，所以它是排他的，但又不是完全排他的，对吧？它不是那种上流社会的隔都，对吧。再次，我认为这表达了荷兰人的一种公民社区意识，这与法国那种宏大浮夸的建筑形成了鲜明对比，尤其是路易十四的专制君主制、天主教君主制。这一定是一个有意识的、刻意的政治对比，荷兰人认为自己是新正如你所说，是公民化的、朴素的，
modest yes yeah absolutely and so looking at the you know this crest that you've mentioned that's on the top of this, and it does look, I mean, it looks very splendid, but it's nothing compared to the coat of arms that you get at Versailles or anything like that, or indeed in the palaces in England. You get these crests and these emblems all over the city. So as scribes, for instance, you'll see a hand with a quill. Or when I came here with Sadie, my wife, she's a midwife, she was very excited to see that there was a stork outside a house, you know, emblem of a midwife who lived there. And my favorite one of all,
朴素的，是的，绝对是的。所以看着你提到的这个徽章，它在房子的顶部，它看起来，我的意思是，它看起来非常壮丽，但与你在凡尔赛宫或其他地方、或者英国的宫殿里看到的家族徽章相比，它什么都不是。你在整个城市到处都能看到这些徽章和标志。比如抄写员，你会看到一只拿着鹅毛笔的手。或者当我带着我的妻子萨迪来到这里时，她是一名助产士，她非常兴奋地看到一所房子外面有一只鹳鸟，你知道，那是住在那里的一位助产士的标志。我最喜欢的，
so there is one of these secret churches that we talked about in the first episode. It was a remonstrant church, so another kind of Protestant sect on the Kaisersgracht. And they bought this building from a guy called Ruthut, which means red hat. And so they advertised this completely secret church by whacking an emblem of a great red hat on it. So that's splendid.
这里有我们在第一集里讨论过的秘密教堂之一。这是一座雷蒙斯特派教堂（Remonstrant church），也就是皇帝运河上的另一个新教教派。他们从一个叫鲁图特（Ruthut，意思是红帽子）的人那里买下了这栋建筑。于是他们通过在这个完全秘密的教堂上挂上一个巨大的红帽子标志来做广告。所以这很了不起。
And what you will also see on lots of these houses, and particularly the houses on the Prinzengracht, but also on the Herrengracht and the Kaisersgracht as well, is that at the top of these houses, and particularly the houses on the Prinzengracht, but also on the Herrengracht and the Kaisersgracht as well, is that at the top of the houses, so where the crest is on the Graf's house, you will see kind of hoist beams. Right, and hooks. Now, I was going to ask you about the hooks.
你还会在许多这样的房子上看到，特别是王子运河上的房子，以及绅士运河和皇帝运河上的房子，在这些房子的顶部——特别是王子运河上的房子，还有绅士运河和皇帝运河上的房子——在房子的顶部，也就是格拉夫宅邸有家族徽章的地方，你会看到一些吊装横梁。没错，还有挂钩。现在，我要问你关于挂钩的事。
So what's all that about? Warehouses or their little stuff? Yes, particularly on the Prinzengracht. So for merchants, their houses double as storehouses and warehouses. And so stuff will be lifted up. Right. And they will keep stuff right at the top of the house.
这到底是是怎么回事？仓库还是用来装小物件的？是的，特别是沿着王子运河。对商人们来说，他们的房子既是住宅又是库房和仓库。所以东西会被吊上去。对。他们会把东西保存在房子的最高处。
But they're not just warehouses, right? So they're not just public spaces, they're private. I mean, we talked last time about their Begeinhof and this inward looking, the sense of privacy and domesticity. And that's true of these houses as well, isn't it? Yes, because the wealth that these merchants have and these kind of great princes of the city enables them to construct within a single domestic space the kind of inward turning the love of privacy that um in the middle ages had been confined within squares um and so whether it is a great kind of you know a mayor of the city like andres de graff or whether it is a kind of much more modest house. Amsterdam in the 17th century in its domestic architecture is committing itself to something that is really novel and incredibly influential. The idea that a house can be a private and personal space. And this is the ideal that I know that both of us have been to see the
但它们不仅仅是仓库，对吧？所以它们不仅仅是公共空间，它们是私密的。我的意思是，我们上一次讨论过贝居安会院（Begeinhof）和这种向内看的特质、对隐私和家庭温馨感的追求。这些房子也是如此，对吧？是的，因为这些商人和城市的伟大王子们所拥有的财富，使他们能够在单一的家庭空间内构建起一种向内转的、对隐私的热爱。在中世纪，这种热爱仅限于广场之内。所以无论是像安德里斯·德·格拉夫这样的市长，还是更朴素的房子。17世纪的阿姆斯特丹在其住宅建筑中致力于一件非常新颖且极具影响力的事情。那就是房子可以成为一个私人和个人空间的理念。我知道我们俩都去参观过这个理想，
Vermeer exhibition, which is on at the Rijksmuseum here in Amsterdam at the moment. And famously, Vermeer is, you know, in his paintings is kind of articulating this sense. And it's the same sense that in the episode that we did on the Dutch maid, the housemaids, you know, English and foreign visitors, when they come here and they walk into the house and the housemaid has just spent all day cleaning the floor and she will attack visitors with her broom and forcibly remove their shoes so that they don't spread dirt in. This obsession with cleanliness, obsession with kind of scrubbing, it's something incredibly momentous. I mean, basically it's the birth of the bourgeois domestic ideal that middle classes across the West and indeed increasingly across the world are now wedded to. And it has its birth here in Amsterdam.
维米尔（Vermeer）画展，目前正在阿姆斯特丹的国家博物馆（Rijksmuseum）展出。众所周知，维米尔在他的画作中表达了这种感觉。这与我们在关于荷兰女佣、女管家的那一集里提到的感觉是一样的，你知道，英国和外国游客来到这里，走进房子，而女佣刚花了一整天时间把地板擦干净，她就会用扫帚袭击游客，强行脱掉他们的鞋子，这样他们就不会把泥土带进来。这种对清洁的痴迷，对擦洗的痴迷，是一件极其重大意义的事情。我的意思是，这基本上是资产阶级家庭理想的诞生，西方乃至世界各地的中产阶级现在都对此深信不疑。它诞生于阿姆斯特丹。
Okay. Let's move on to the next location in just a second. So we are going to be moving on to the Royal Palace now. Very exciting. So let's go there. Right. So I mentioned how these houses on the canals need a lot of wood and support. The Royal Palace, which is back on Dam Square. square i mean that really does require an awful lot of wood and we're going to look at it now so tom you were just talking to me about wood that was very exciting i was um and we've moved back to um dam square where we began and we're facing this enormous building and i believe you're going to say talk to me some more about wood yes so this this was the um the town hall that was opened by andres de graff's brother cornelis right um on the 29th of july 1655 and when it was built it was by miles the largest building in amsterdam in fact it
好的。我们马上转到下一个地点。所以我们要去皇家王宫了。非常令人兴奋。我们去那里吧。好的。所以刚才我提到运河上的这些房子需要大量的木头和支撑物。皇家王宫位于水坝广场（Dam Square），我的意思是，那里的确需要大量的木头，我们现在就去看看。所以汤姆，你刚刚跟我谈论了木头，这非常令人兴奋。是的，我们回到了我们开始的水坝广场，我们正对着这座巨大的建筑，我相信你会继续跟我谈论木头。是的，这是由安德里斯·德·格拉夫的兄弟科内利斯（Cornelis）于1655年7月29日揭幕的市政厅。对。当它建成时，它是阿姆斯特丹绝对是最大的建筑，事实上它
was one of the largest buildings in europe i think saint peter's in rome the scorial the dojo palace in venice were basically the only buildings that could rival it so it's a very very large kind of 17th century palace basically pretty monumental yeah it is and the total number of wood required to support this because it's basically floating on a bog right 13 659659 pieces of Scandinavian timber. Right, crikey. And this was the town hall. So it was a monument not to a king or a royal family, but to sort of civic virtue. To civic virtue.
是欧洲最大的建筑之一。我想罗马的圣彼得大教堂、埃斯科里亚尔修道院、威尼斯的总督宫基本上是仅有的能与它媲美的建筑。所以这是一座非常非常大的17世纪宫殿，可以说是相当宏伟。是的，确实如此。支撑这座建筑所需的木材总数，因为它是浮在一片沼泽上的，对吧？13,659根斯堪的纳维亚木材。对，天哪。这就是市政厅。所以它不是为了纪念国王或王室，而是为了某种公民美德。为了公民美德。
And so inside, it is decorated with all kinds of improving murals. So you've got scenes from classical history, obviously scenes from the Bible, illustrating patriotic sacrifice, incorruptibility, civic virtue, lots of comparisons being made between Amsterdam and ancient Israel. That's one thing you haven't mentioned that I was going to ask you about. So people in the Dutch Republic, they do have a sense of themselves as a kind of chosen people, yes, absolutely. They do. And, and also it's rather like the east india house which is situating amsterdam as the kind of the center of the turning world yeah this is made
所以在内部，它装饰了各种各样寓意深刻的壁画。所以你有来自古典历史的场景，显然还有圣经中的场景，说明爱国牺牲、清正廉洁、公民美德，并将阿姆斯特丹与古代以色列进行了许多比较。这是你没提到的一点，我想问你。所以荷兰共和国的人们，他们确实有一种自己是某种“选民”的感觉，是的，绝对是的。他们有。而且，这也非常类似于东印度公司，它将阿姆斯特丹定位为旋转世界的中心，这在
manifest inside the the city hall because you have a great map of the world there with amsterdam absolutely at its center and this building becomes the emblem for the greatness, the wealth, the power of Amsterdam and of the Dutch Republic more generally. And so there's a famous encomium that is given by a palpably very, very jealous Englishman, a man called William Algianby, who was a fellow of the Royal Society in the mid 17th century, who said that scarce any subject occurs more frequent in the discourse of ingenious men than that of the marvellous progress of this little state, which in the space of about 100 years, hath grown to a height not only infinitely transcending all the ancient republics of Greece, but not much inferior in some respects, even to the greatest monarchies of these later ages.
市政厅内部得到了体现，因为那里有一张巨大的世界地图，而阿姆斯特丹绝对位于地图的中心。这座建筑成为了阿姆斯特丹乃至整个荷兰共和国的伟大、财富和权力的象征。因此，17世纪中期英国皇家学会会员威廉·阿尔金比（William Algianby）这位显然非常非常嫉妒的英国人对此有一段著名的赞美之词。他说：“在才华横溢之人的言谈中，很少有什么主题比这个小国奇迹般的崛起更频繁地出现。这个小国在短短大约100年的时间里，不仅高度无限超越了希腊所有的古代共和国，而且在某些方面甚至不比晚近时期最伟大的君主国逊色多少。”
The irony is, Tom, that precisely this moment, the 1650s and then the 1660s and so on, the Dutch are fighting wars against the English, winning some of them. And the French in due course. And the French. But of course, they are about to be outstripped by the marvellous progress of an even more admirable state.
讽刺的是，汤姆，恰恰在这个时刻，即17世纪50年代、60年代及以后，荷兰人正在与英国人交战，其中有些战争还赢了。还有随后的法国人。还有法国人。但当然，他们即将被一个更令人钦佩的国家的奇迹般进步所超越。
Am I wrong? Well, so the English in particular are incredibly jealous of the Dutch. So we have had occasion before to speak of the disgraceful behaviour of the Dutch fleet in raiding the naval dockyards at Chatham, the raid on the Medway. So there is absolutely Anglo-Dutch rivalry throughout the 1650s under Cromwell, throughout the 1660s under Charles II.
我没说错吧？嗯，特别是英国人对荷兰人生嫉妒。所以我们以前曾提及荷兰舰队袭击查塔姆海军造船厂的不光彩行为，即对麦德威河的袭击。所以在克伦威尔统治下的17世纪50年代，以及查理二世统治下的17世纪60年代，始终存在着英荷竞争。
And then, of course, under James II, who's a Catholic, the Stadtholder, William III, who we talked about while we were standing outside Andries de Graaf's house. Yes. You know, he's a little boy when his dad dies of smallpox. But by 1688, he's the most impressive protestant leader in europe and basically 1688 he launches an invasion of england yeah he occupies london and it's effectively a merger between amsterdam and london between the two great capitalist engines this is not really a conquest is it in the set he's been invited by kind of weak oligarchs.
然后，当然，在天主教徒詹姆斯二世统治时期，我们在安德里斯·德·格拉夫的宅邸外谈到的执政官威廉三世。是的。你知道，当他的父亲死于天花时，他还是个小男孩。但到1688年，他是欧洲最具印象深刻的新教领袖，基本上在1688年，他发动了对英格兰的入侵，对，他占领了伦敦，这实际上是阿姆斯特丹和伦敦、两个伟大资本主义引擎之间的合并。这其实并不是一次征服，对吧？他是应一些软弱的寡头之邀而来的。
And there is a real sense of a kind of merger of the sort of the wealth, the manpower, the resources of England, the naval resources and so on with the naus, the financial innovations, the sort of civic culture, the ambition of the Dutch. Yeah. I mean, you see the influence of dutch in all kinds of english maritime words so yacht is a dutch word right blunderbuss schooner all that kind of thing so the influence of dutch capitalism and dutch globalism on the english is enormous both as an inspiration and as a kind of rivalry and so basically by the the late 17th going into the 18th century, there's a sense in which the English are doing to the Dutch what the Dutch had done to the Portuguese.
这里确实有一种合并的感觉，即英格兰的财富、人力、资源、海军资源等与荷兰的航海术、金融创新、公民文化和雄心壮志的融合。是的。你看，英语中各种航海词汇都受到了荷兰语的影响，比如“yacht”（游艇）是一个荷兰词，对吧，“blunderbuss”（短枪）、“schooner”（双桅纵帆船）诸如此类。因此，荷兰资本主义和荷兰全球主义对英国人的影响是巨大的，既是一种灵感，也是一种竞争。所以基本上，在17世纪末到18世纪，某种程度上，英国人正在对荷兰人做荷兰人对葡萄牙人做过的事。
That's karma, Tom. But I want to ask you, we're in Amsterdam, we'd be talking about Amsterdam, but what about New Amsterdam? So that's what becomes New York. So is that a kind of symbol of that? Yeah, absolutely. Because New Amsterdam is a Dutch settlement, but gets lost to the English by terms of a treaty that ends one of the kind of perennial
那是因果报应，汤姆。但我想问你，我们在阿姆斯特丹，我们一直在谈论阿姆斯特丹，但新阿姆斯特丹呢？那就是后来的纽约。所以那是那种现象的一个象征吗？是的，绝对是的。因为新阿姆斯特丹是荷兰的定居点，但根据结束了一场旷日持久的
Anglo-Dutch wars and becomes New York. So that's the perfect kind of illustration of this process whereby the Dutch East India Company, also on the other side of the world, is increasingly put under the shadow in India of the British East India Company. So in the 18th century, Holland is regressing, isn't it? It's falling down the table of world powers. It is, but there's a sense in which, I mean, it's still fabulously rich. It's still very, very significant center, but I think it is coming to seem less exceptional. So the path blazed by the Dutch is one that others are now following. I mean, one way in which the Netherlands and Amsterdam in particular does remain incredibly significant is that the tradition that was there right the way through
英荷战争的条约，它被割让给了英国，并成为了纽约。所以这完美地说明了这样一个过程：荷兰东印度公司在世界另一端，在印度的地位也日益被英国东印度公司所掩盖。所以在18世纪，荷兰正在倒退，对吧？它的世界大国排名正在下降。确实如此，但在某种程度上——我的意思是，它依然极其富有。它仍然是一个非常非常重要的中心，但我认为它开始显得没那么独特了。因此，荷兰人开辟的道路现在正被其他人所效仿。我的意思是，荷兰特别是阿姆斯特丹仍然极其重要的一个方面是，那种从
the 16th and 17th centuries of this being a place where you could say and think and publish things that you couldn't do anywhere else yeah that remains a very very kind of vivid tradition the paradigmatic figure who illustrates that is spinoza a jew who famously gets kind of excommunicated by the jewish community here in amsterdam and whose writings they like the touch paper to what Jonathan Israel, the great historian of early modern Netherlands and the Enlightenment, has called the radical Enlightenment. So throughout the 18th century, books that are incredibly scandalous. So the most notorious is a book called The Three Impostors. And The Three Impostors are Moses, Jesus, and Muhammad.
16世纪和17世纪一直延续下来的传统，即这里是一个你可以说、想、并发表你在其他任何地方都不能做的事情的地方，对，这仍然是一个非常非常生动的传统。阐明这一点的典型人物是斯宾诺莎，一个犹太人，他因在阿姆斯特丹的犹太社群中被逐出教会而闻名，他的著作犹如导火索，点燃了早期现代荷兰和启蒙运动的伟大历史学家乔纳森·以色列（Jonathan Israel）所称的“激进启蒙运动”。所以在整个18世纪，都有一些极其离经叛道的书籍出版。其中最声名狼藉的是一本名为《三位大骗子》的书。这三位大骗子是摩西、耶稣和穆罕默德。
Right. And that's published in Amsterdam. And really, I mean, it's the only place where you could publish it. Yeah. And that's drawing on the legacy of Amsterdam, not just as a great capitalist entrepot, but it's a place where people from other countries come to explore and express ideas that can't be explored and expressed elsewhere. Yeah. So Descartes, we've mentioned already.
没错。这本书是在阿姆斯特丹出版的。说实话，这里几乎是唯一能出版它的地方。是的。这汲取了阿姆斯特丹的遗产，它不仅是一个伟大的资本主义转口港，而且是一个让来自其他国家的人们前来探索和表达在其他地方无法探索和表达的思想的地方。是的。所以笛卡尔，我们已经提到了。
Descartes spends... Tom, they're loving you. They love it, yes. The people are applauding over there. Descartes comes here. Thomas Hobbes is published here. Locke comes here. Yeah.
笛卡尔在这里度过……汤姆，他们太喜欢你了。他们真的很喜欢，是的。那边的人们在鼓掌。笛卡尔来到了这里。托马斯·霍布斯的作品在这里出版。洛克也来到了这里。是的。
So there is absolutely a sense in which this remains kind of, in intellectual terms, you know, incredibly important. And so when in the second half of the 18th century, you get first the American Revolution and then the French Revolution, there is a sense in the part of people in amsterdam who feel well this is an expression of of stuff that we started right but then they end up fighting the french don't they the french invade in what 1795 well actually kind of less than you would think because there's such enthusiasm first for the American cause, um, against the British very shameful behavior on the part of the, of the Amsterdamers.
所以绝对有一种感觉，在知识层面上，这里依然保持着令人难以置信的重要性。因此，在18世纪后半叶，先是发生了美国革命，然后是法国革命，阿姆斯特丹的人们有一种感觉，他们觉得“这正是我们开始的事情的一种表达”，但后来他们最终与法国人开战了，不是吗？法国人在什么时候入侵的？1795年。嗯，实际上比你想象的要少，因为人们起初对美国的事业充满热情，
Yeah. But then in, in the, in the French revolution, large numbers of people in Amsterdam are on the side of the French revolutionaries to the degree that the, the stat holder who's still, you know, a descendant of William the silent, um, the house of orange, he goes into exile in england and um dutch revolutionaries in amsterdam proclaim a republic so it becomes the batavian republic after the batavians who are the kind of the ancient people who lived in this vicinity um back in the early roman times and the french invade the d Dutch revolutionaries rise up, and it's a little bit like 1688 in reverse.
反对英国人——阿姆斯特丹人的表现非常可耻。是的。但随后，在法国大革命期间，阿姆斯特丹的大量民众站在了法国革命者这一边，以至于执政官——他仍然是沉默者威廉的后代，也就是奥兰治家族——流亡到了英国，而阿姆斯特丹的荷兰革命者宣布成立共和国。于是它成为了巴达维亚共和国（Batavian Republic），以早期罗马时代生活在这个附近的古代民族巴达维亚人命名。法国人入侵，荷兰革命者起义，这有点像1688年的反转版。
It's both an invasion and a revolution and a merger. So the Batavian Republic is proclaimed in January 1795, and the Dutch welcome the French to Amsterdam by hanging tricolours over the canals. So hurrah for the Republic. The Dutch have this indigenous tradition of republicanism that doesn't actually need the French to inspire them. But the French, I'm afraid, then behave very badly.
这既是一场入侵，又是一场革命，还是一次融合。因此，巴达维亚共和国于1795年1月宣告成立，荷兰人通过在运河上悬挂三色旗来欢迎法国人来到阿姆斯特丹。所以，为共和国欢呼吧。荷兰人拥有本土的共和主义传统，其实并不需要法国人来启发他们。但恐怕法国人后来表现得很糟糕。
You astound me. They badly let the Dutch republicans down. Because in 1806, Napoleon installs his younger brother, Louis, as king. Oh, yes. And so Louis moves into the city hall, the town hall. Oh, the building. Over there, which is the great emblem of Dutch republicanism. Yeah.
你可真让我大吃一惊。他们严重辜负了荷兰共和党人的期望。因为在1806年，拿破仑将他的弟弟路易立为国王。哦，是的。于是路易搬进了市政厅。哦，天哪。那边的那座建筑，它是荷兰共和主义的伟大象征。是的。
And he turns it into the royal palace. Of course he does. He's actually surprisingly popular. So he goes to great lengths to learn Dutch. And everybody who's shown me around Amsterdam always tells the same story. My Dutch probably isn't up to recycling it, but apparently his Dutch was very bad. I mean, who am I to cast a stone? And he described himself as Koen van Olland rather than Koen van Holland. So this apparently is hilarious because apparently
他把它变成了皇家王宫。他当然这么做了。他其实出奇地受欢迎。所以他付出了巨大努力来学习荷兰语。所有带我参观阿姆斯特丹的人总是讲同一个故事。我的荷兰语可能不足以复述它，但显然他的荷兰语非常糟糕。我算什么人呢，怎么好意思扔石头呢？他称自己为“Koen van Olland”而不是“Koen van Holland”。这显然非常滑稽，因为显然
he was calling himself the rabbit of Holland. So this apparently is hilarious because apparently it means he was calling himself the rabbit of Holland. I genuinely heard someone saying that in the street yesterday. Right. To a group of tourists.
他是在称自己为“荷兰的兔子”。这显然非常滑稽，因为显然这意味着他自称是“荷兰的兔子”。我昨天在街上真的听到有人对一群游客这么说。
So it's a great story. Clearly this is the one Dutch story. About Louis Napoleon. Yeah. So he became himself a rabbit rather than the king.
所以这是一个伟大的故事。显然这就是关于路易·拿破仑的那个荷兰故事。关于路易·拿破仑。是的。所以他把自己变成了一只兔子而不是国王。
And he was such a good king that he got called Louis the Good. Right. So he sets up the museum that in the long run will become the Rijksmuseum.
而且他是一个如此优秀的国王，以至于人们称他为“好人路易”（Louis the Good）。没错。所以他建立了日后将成为国家博物馆的博物馆。
Oh, see. So the Rijksm museum is founded by a frenchman which is really something yeah but generally isn't theo our producer loves this he's nodding away he purports to be french but um but napoleon is very contemptuous of this title that that louis napoleon gets of louis the the good um and says that brother when they say of some king or other that he is good it means that he has failed in his rule i'm with napoleon on that actually absolutely well but i think napoleon is saying this because in 1810 he he basically abolishes the kingdom of of the netherlands just resorts into france so amsterdam becomes part of greater france um and then in 1813 napoleon's empire is collapsing the french withdraw Willem comes back from exile the Stadtholder
哦，你看。所以国家博物馆是由一个法国人创立的，这可真了不得，是的。但总的来说，我们的制作人西奥（Theo）很喜欢这个，他正点头呢，他自称是法国人，不过——但拿破仑对路易·拿破仑获得“好人路易”这个称号感到非常轻蔑，并说：“兄弟，当他们称某个国王为‘好人’时，这意味着他的统治失败了。”在这点上我其实挺赞同拿破仑的，绝对的。不过，我认为拿破仑这么说是因为在1810年，他基本上废除了荷兰王国，将其并入法国，所以阿姆斯特丹成为了大法国的一部分；然后到1813年，拿破仑帝国崩溃，法国人撤退，执政官威廉从流亡中归来，
and is proclaimed king so he's the first Dutch king so the city hall remains the royal palace and it is the royal palace to this day 19th century things speed up but Tom you know what you haven't talked about what?
并被宣告为国王，所以他是第一位荷兰国王。因此，市政厅保留为皇家王宫，直到今天它依然是皇家王宫。19世纪，节奏加快了，但汤姆，你知道你还没谈到什么吗？什么？
that the Dutch never talk about what? because they're ashamed what? the loss of Belgium so the Belgian Revolution, when the Belgians cast off Dutch oppression.
荷兰人从不谈论什么？什么？比利时的独立。也就是比利时革命，当比利时人摆脱荷兰压迫的时候。
But it's nothing really to do with Amsterdam, is it? Well, it's the dark side of the Dutch character, isn't it? No.
但这其实跟阿姆斯特丹没什么关系，对吧？嗯，那是荷兰人性格中黑暗的一面，不是吗？不。
They were such hideous overlords that the Belgians couldn't take it. Everything in 19th century Amsterdam, it's still very liberal, Dominic. Very progressive.
他们是如此可怕的统治者，以至于比利时人无法忍受。19世纪的阿姆斯特丹的一切，仍然非常自由，多米尼克。非常进步。
So the first railway station is built in... I'm going to put my cards on the table, Tom. I actually prefer Belgium to Holland. I think the food is better. I think the food is better
所以第一座火车站建于……我要摊牌了，汤姆。我其实比荷兰更喜欢比利时。我认为食物更好。我认为食物在比利时更好。
in Belgium. I love Belgium, but I... The chips are better in Belgium. I love Holland better. Holland has a better name. Go on. Finish your...
在比利时。我喜欢比利时，但我……比利时的炸薯条更好。我更喜欢荷兰。荷兰的名字更好听。说吧。把你的话说完……
Okay. Okay. So railways, First Dutch Railway built in 1839. They've got all of them in Belgium as well. I know, I know, I know.
好吧。好吧。所以铁路，第一条荷兰铁路建于1839年。比利时也都有这些。我知道，我知道，我知道。
So actually, although they're built later, the Rijksmuseum and the Railway Central Station are both built by a Catholic. Are they? Yeah, so if you like Belgium, art galleries and railway stations built by Catholics, Amsterdam's got them too. So there you go.
所以实际上，尽管它们建得较晚，但国家博物馆和铁路中央车站都是由天主教徒建造的。是吗？是的，所以如果你喜欢比利时、由天主教徒建造的艺术馆和火车站，阿姆斯特丹也有这些。所以你看。
1848, we talked about with Christopher Clarke. He sang about it. He did, yes. That this kind of liberal revolution basically establishes the Dutch constitution that survives to this day. So the Dutch have, at this point, they're a monarchy. They are, and they're still a monarchy.
1848年，我们和克里斯托夫·克拉克（Christopher Clarke）谈过。他歌颂过它。他确实唱过，是的。这种自由主义革命基本上确立了延续至今的荷兰宪法。所以荷兰人，在这个时候，他们是一个君主国。他们是，而且他们现在依然是一个君主国。
Yeah. I mean, that's the interesting thing, isn't it? Were it not for the French Revolution and Napoleon, that they would still be a republic. Yeah. So the French Revolution results in the city palace becoming the royal palace. The irony. Yeah.
是的。我的意思是，这很有趣，不是吗？要不是法国大革命和拿破仑，他们现在可能还是个共和国。是的。所以法国大革命导致城市宫殿变成了皇家王宫。真具有讽刺意味。是的。
And then it becomes one of these European cities that are kind of motors of international capitalism and industrialized capitalism in the late 19th century. They've always been a very commercial people, a polite and commercial people. And really where we're sitting now in Dam Square is the perfect exemplification of that. The beehive. The beehive. The beehinkorf. The beehinkorf, Tom. Sorry, sorry. Neither of us, by the way, speak Dutch, but do address all your, as I've already said, address all your remarks to Tom, please, not to me. So it's founded in 1870 as a haberdashery store. But it's rebuilt in 1909, basically to be the Dutch Selfridges.
然后它成为了19世纪后期作为国际资本主义和工业化资本主义引擎的欧洲城市之一。他们一直是一个非常商业化的民族，一个礼貌而商业化的民族。我们现在坐的水坝广场，真的是对这一点的完美诠释。蜂巢百货公司。蜂巢。De Bijenkorf。De Bijenkorf，汤姆。抱歉，抱歉。顺便说一下，我们两个都不会说荷兰语，但正如我之前所说，请把所有的评论都对准汤姆，不要对着我。所以它于1870年作为一家杂货店创立。但它在1909年进行了重建，基本上成为了荷兰版的塞尔福里奇百货（Selfridges）。
And in fact, it is owned today by the Selfridges Group. Now, Tom, I do like a department store and I also like a trinket or knickknack or souvenir. A clog, a windmill. I'd like to get a miniature windmill. That's what I'd like to get.
事实上，它今天由塞尔福里奇集团所有。现在，汤姆，我确实喜欢百货公司，我也喜欢小饰品、小玩意儿或纪念品。木鞋，风车。我想买个微型风车。这就是我想买的东西。
Cheese wrapped up in red wax. Shall we go over there right now let's go and do that and do you have um perhaps a card i've got my wise card your wise my wise app match i'm going to be using the app on my phone i heartily recommend it to our listeners let's go and do that right now so tom here we are and we've actually gone to a different place we went to 100 holland you chose this shop for narcissistic reasons. It literally had my name on it. It had your name on it. Now, we've selected this lovely tin of Holland waffles. Stroopwafel, I think they call them.
用红蜡包裹的奶酪。我们现在就过去看看吧，顺便买一点，你身上有……也许有一张卡吗？我有我的Wise卡。你的Wise，我的Wise，应用程序匹配，我打算在手机上用这个App。我由衷地向听众朋友们推荐它。我们现在就过去吧。好了，汤姆，我们到了，实际上我们来到了一个不同的地方。我们去了“100 Holland”，你出于自恋的原因选择了这家店。这店名简直就写着我的名字。确实写着你的名字。现在，我们选了一罐可爱的荷兰华夫饼。我想他们管这叫焦糖华夫饼（Stroopwafel）。
I'm going to pay for them, Tom, with something very exciting. I'm going to pay for them with my Wise app. Because the thing about Wise, you can spend in 40 different currencies. And if you're on the go, as you so often are with your travels, and you don't have the local currency in your Wise account, Tom, they were auto-converted at the mid-market exchange rate with absolutely no markups and no hidden fees. Because I hate a markup and I hate a hidden fee. Well, you don't have to worry.
汤姆，我要用一件非常令人兴奋的东西来付钱。我要用我的Wise App来付钱。因为Wise的特点是，你可以在40种不同的货种中进行消费。如果你在旅途中，正如你旅游时经常的那样，并且你的Wise账户里没有当地货币，汤姆，它们会以中间市场汇率自动转换，绝对没有加价，也没有隐藏费用。因为我讨厌加价，也讨厌隐藏费用。好吧，你完全不用担心。
So Wise is the card for me. You're in 100% Holland. You've got your Wise thing. No markups. You're laughing. I literally you don't have to worry. Wise is the card for me. You're in 100% Holland. You've got your wise thing. No markups. You're laughing. I literally couldn't be happier. Right. Brilliant.
所以Wise就是最适合我的卡。你身处百分之百的荷兰。你有了你的Wise。没有加价。你可乐了。我真的——你完全不用担心。Wise就是最适合我的卡。你身处百分之百的荷兰。你有了你的Wise。没有加价。你可乐了。我真的开心得无以复加。好。太棒了。
Everybody's happy. Let's go and pay for these waffles. Hello. Let's pay for these lovely waffles, please. Yes, please. Thank you.
大家都很高兴。我们去为这些华夫饼付钱吧。你好。我们来为这些可爱的华夫饼付钱吧，谢谢。好的，谢谢。
Just going to pay with my wise app here. That was incredibly convenient, Dominic. Thank you. Thank going to pay with my Wise app here. That was incredibly convenient, Dominic. Thank you. Thank you, Bill. No markups, no hidden charges. Wonderful. That's probably the best transaction I think I've ever done.
我这就用我的Wise App付款。这真是不可思议地便捷，多米尼克。谢谢。等等，我这就用我的Wise App付款。这真是不可思议地便捷，多米尼克。谢谢。谢谢你，比尔。没有加价，没有隐藏费用。太棒了。这可能是我做过最好的交易了。
So, Tom, we've just moved 10 minutes down the road, and we were talking about the Beehive, the Beienkopf, and the founder of that haberdashery store. The interesting thing about him, Simon Philipp Goldschmidt, he was Jewish. He was. As by the 1930s, almost 15% of the population was Jewish. Right. 15 of the population was jewish right there were 80 000 in amsterdam and the roots of the jewish population in amsterdam go back as so much does in this city to the 17th century right you amaze me so you remember that in the first part we were talking about how uh the beguines and the anabaptists and the mennonites and the Remonstrants and all these various guys are
所以，汤姆，我们刚刚沿着路向前走了10分钟，我们刚才在谈论“蜂巢”（The Beehive，即De Bijenkorf）以及那家百货公司的创始人。关于他，西蒙·菲利普·戈德施密特（Simon Philipp Goldschmidt），有趣的是，他是犹太人。他确实是。到了20世纪30年代，近15%的人口都是犹太人。没错。15%的人口是犹太人，没错。阿姆斯特丹当时有8万犹太人，而阿姆斯特丹犹太人口的根源，就像这座城市的许多事物一样，可以追溯到17世纪。没错，你真让我惊叹。所以你还记得，在第一部分中，我们谈到过……呃，贝居安修女（beguines）、再洗礼派（anabaptists）、门诺派（mennonites）、
setting up their own communities and the Calvinist city authorities are kind of legalizing them, kind of not. They're kind of operating. And the same approach is brought to Jewish settlers. And the word gets out to Jews in the Iberian Peninsula, Sephardic Jews, as they're called. And particularly from Portugal, they start moving to Amsterdam. Because this is, of course, the moment at which, in Spain and Portugal, the authorities are moving very aggressively against local Jews. So obviously, Amsterdam must seem, by comparison, a haven of tolerance. Completely. amsterdam must seem by comparison a haven of tolerance completely um so in contrast to the inquisition that you're getting in portugal here within a few years of of jews being allowed to
雷蒙斯特派（Remonstrants）以及所有这些形形色色的人是如何建立自己的社区的，而加尔文主义的城市当局则有点像是在将他们合法化，又有点没有。他们某种程度上在运作。同样的态度也被带到了犹太定居者身上。这个消息传到了伊比利亚半岛的犹太人那里，也就是所谓的塞法迪犹太人（Sephardic Jews）。特别是从葡萄牙开始，他们开始移居阿姆斯特丹。因为这当然是西班牙和葡萄牙当局对当地犹太人采取极其严厉打击的时期。所以相比之下，阿姆斯特丹必定显得像是一个宽容的避风港。完全是这样。相比之下，阿姆斯特丹必定显得像是一个宽容的避风港。完全是这样。嗯，所以与你在葡萄牙遇到的宗教裁判所形成鲜明对比的是，在犹太人被允许在这里定居的几年内，
settle here they are allowed to worship openly and freely so they they can stop pretending to be kind of christian yeah and and openly practice judaism and more and more numbers of of jews from portugal come here and the the area that we in, we're just down from the house that Rembrandt bought, just a few minutes walk down from there. And this became one of, it was kind of like Little Lisbon. Everyone here speaking in Portuguese. And some very famous names came from this community. One of them, Manasseh ben Israel, is the rabbi who went to London to convince Cromwell to allow Jews to return to England. They've been expelled by Edward I.
他们被允许公开、自由地做礼拜。所以他们可以不再假装自己是什么基督徒了，对吧，并且能够公开践行犹太教。来自葡萄牙的犹太人数量越来越多，而我们所在的区域——我们就在伦勃朗买下的房子往下走一点，从那里步行只需几分钟。这里变成了其中一个……它有点像“小里斯本”。这里的每个人都在说葡萄牙语。这个社区里诞生了一些非常著名的名字。其中一位，马拿西·本·以色列（Manasseh ben Israel），是一位犹太 rabbis，他曾前往伦敦说服克伦威尔允许犹太人返回英格兰。他们曾被爱德华一世驱逐出境。
He's very successful. And probably the most famous name of all is Spinoza, the great philosopher who we mentioned a little bit earlier, the hero of the radical enlightenment. But just going back to Manasseh Ben Israel, the guy who gets the Jews into London, Bevis Marks, which is the first Jewish synagogue to be opened in London in the 17th century, it's rather like the Beguinhof. There's a doorway on a kind of city street and you wouldn't know what was inside unless you went there. But the place that I've brought you to is very very
他非常成功。而其中最著名的名字可能要数斯宾诺莎（Spinoza）了，这位伟大的哲学家我们刚才稍微提到过，他是激进启蒙运动的英雄。但回过头来看马拿西·本·以色列，那个把犹太人带回伦敦的人，贝维斯马克犹太会堂（Bevis Marks）是17世纪在伦敦开设的第一座犹太会堂，它有点像贝居安会院（Beguinhof）。城市街道上只有一个入口，如果你不去的话，根本不知道里面有什么。但我带你来的这个地方非常非常
different because the synagogue here portuguese synagogue as it's still called the eisenoga is on a massive scale it couldn't be less like the big enough because it's it's not inward looking it's a huge monumental building i mean huge and monumental by any standards but certainly by the standards of 17th century amsterdam yeah um so this is what 1675 something like that completed in 1675 and it's designed to look like solomon's temple so it's modeled on the the proportions um given for solomon's temple in the bible inside it's it's incredible i mean it has this massive barrel vaulted ceiling candles everywhere back in the 17th century the floor was made of sand um so an incredible statement about
不同，因为这里的犹太会堂——葡萄牙犹太会堂（Portuguese Synagogue），正如人们至今仍这样称呼它的那样，Esnoga——规模极其宏大。它再怎么不像贝居安会院也不为过了，因为它不是内向型的，而是一座巨大的、具有纪念意义的建筑物。我是说，无论是按什么标准来看，它都是巨大而宏伟的，尤其是以17世纪阿姆斯特丹的标准来看。是的，嗯，所以这是……1675年左右？在1675年完工，它的设计看起来像所罗门圣殿（Solomon's Temple），所以它是根据圣经中给出的所罗门圣殿的比例建造的。里面太不可思议了。我是说，它有着巨大的筒形拱顶天花板，到处都是蜡烛。在17世纪，地板铺满了沙子……因此，这是一个令人难以置信的声明，
basically how confident the jews were in the tolerance of the city that had given them host yes that they could advertise their presence in this way without Without fearing any backlash. Without fearing any backlash. Right. And nothing in Dutch life since the 17th century gives them any reason to think that that will change. I mean, they're incredibly well integrated. Yes. But of course, notoriously, and the one thing that everyone around the world knows about what happens in amsterdam in the war is that the germans invade and the jews suffer terrible persecution because of the iconic figure of anne frank right so i was wondering why you haven't picked anne frank's house as one of the as one of your destinations but obviously this building tells the story just as well
基本上表明了犹太人对接纳他们的这座城市的宽容度有多么自信，是的，他们可以以这种方式公开他们的存在，而不必担心任何反弹。而不必担心任何反弹。没错。自17世纪以来荷兰生活的方方面面，都没有给他们任何理由认为这种情况会改变。我的意思是，他们融入得非常好。是的。但当然，众所周知，全世界的人都知道发生在战争期间阿姆斯特丹的一件事，那就是德国人入侵了，由于安妮·弗兰克（Anne Frank）这个标志性人物，犹太人遭受了可怕的迫害。没错。所以我一直在想，你为什么没有把安妮·弗兰克故居作为你的目的地之一呢？但很显然，这座建筑同样能很好地讲述这段历史，
um and it's more surprising choice is. This is testament to the success and the integration of Jews into Dutch life. Yeah, so the sense of this being a ghetto, I mean, this was very much where Jews had settled in the 17th century. But by the 1940s, they've scattered out across Amsterdam. So the Franks would be an obvious example of that.
而且这是一个更令人意外的选择。这是犹太人成功融入荷兰生活的证明。是的，所以这里曾是一个贫民窟的感觉——我的意思是，这很大程度上是17世纪犹太人定居的地方。但到了20世纪40年代，他们已经散布到阿姆斯特丹的各个角落。所以弗兰克一家就是一个明显的例子。
They live out beyond the canals would be an obvious example of that. They live out beyond the canals. And so you might think that that would make it difficult for the Nazis to round the Jews up, but unfortunately not. Basically because of two distinctive features of life in Amsterdam and the Netherlandslands more generally one of which is that as society in the netherlands becomes kind of more culturally complex less monolithically calvinist they develop this concept that in english is called pillarization this idea that there are
他们住在运河区以外，这就是一个明显的例子。他们住在运河区以外。所以你可能会认为这会使纳粹很难搜捕犹太人，但不幸的是并非如此。基本上是因为阿姆斯特丹和整个荷兰生活的两个鲜明特征：其中之一是，随着荷兰社会的文化日益复杂，不再那么单一地由加尔文主义主导，他们发展出了一个在英语中被称为“顶柱化”（pillarization，或译为社群分化/垂直分层）的概念。这个理念是，存在着
different pillars say catholic calvinist um whatever socialist, liberal, that society is considered forming different pillars and that therefore you are catalogued and categorised as belonging to one of these particular pillars. And each pillar has its own institutions, right? Yes. So it's kind of vertical, sort of vertical integration. So it has its own newspapers, schools, banks, radio stations, and the Jews are catalogued in the socialist pillar. Right. So confirming the Nazis' darker suspicions of the Jews.
不同的“柱子”，比方说天主教、加尔文主义……无论是什么，社会主义者、自由主义者，整个社会被认为是由不同的柱子构成的，因此你会被归档并分类为属于这些特定柱子中的某一个。而每一根柱子都有自己的机构，对吗？是的。所以这是一种垂直的、某种程度上的垂直整合。所以它有自己的报纸、学校、银行、广播电台，而犹太人则被归类在社会主义支柱中。没错。这证实了纳粹对犹太人的黑暗猜疑。
And that means that they, because they're catalogued, their addresses are on file and they're marked as being Jewish. Oh, right. Crikey. Okay. And the other thing is that the Netherlands has Europe's most counterfeit proof identity card. Right, so you can't escape. So again, there's kind of no escape.
这意味着，因为他们被建档了，他们的地址都在档案里，并且被标明是犹太人。哦，天哪。天哪，好吧。另一件事是，荷兰拥有欧洲防伪性能最好的身份证。没错，所以你无法逃脱。所以同样地，基本上无处可逃。
Now, the process by which the Nazis start to persecute the Jews is gradual. So the Germans declare war on the Netherlands on the 9th of May, 1940. I mean, the Dutch, they don't have tanks. They have two cyclist regiments. Sorry, I saw a slideshow in the Anne Frank house. They had two tanks, the guide said, one of which was broken. Yeah. And they had a regiment of, yeah, those regiments of cyclists.
现在，纳粹开始迫害犹太人的过程是渐进的。因此，德国人于1940年5月9日对荷兰宣战。我的意思是，荷兰人没有坦克。他们有两个自行车团。抱歉，我在安妮·弗兰克故居看到过一个幻灯片。导游说他们有两辆坦克，其中一辆还坏了。是的。他们有一个团的……是的，那些自行车团。
Who were incredibly brave. Right. I mean, they suffered terrible casualties. Yeah. And of course, the reason that the Netherlands surrenders is that Rotterdam gets, the center of Rotterdam gets bombed. Yeah. And the surrender is basically, I suppose, what saves Amsterdam because otherwise the
他们极其勇敢。我是说，他们遭受了可怕的伤亡。是的。当然，荷兰之所以投降，是因为鹿特丹被轰炸了，鹿特丹的中心被炸毁了。是的。而投降基本上，我想，正是拯救了阿姆斯特丹的原因，否则
same fate might have been visited on Amsterdam. So the Germans occupy Amsterdam on the 15th of May. So that's, you know, less than a week after the declaration of war. And to begin with, because the Dutch are seen as being Aryan, they are part of the racial community that the Nazis are celebrating, the repression in the Netherlands is not as bad as it might have been. And even Jews are not immediately targeted. So there's that famous footage, again, I'm sure you must have seen it in the Anne Frank house, of the wedding wedding party which is waving from a window she's waving from a window so it's it's possible
同样的命运可能也会降临到阿姆斯特丹头上。因此，德国人在5月15日占领了阿姆斯特丹。所以，你知道，这距离宣战不到一周时间。起初，由于荷兰人被视为雅利安人，他们是纳粹所赞美的那种种族共同体的一部分，所以在荷兰的镇压并没有原本可能那么严重。甚至犹太人也没有立即成为攻击目标。所以有一个著名的镜头——再次强调，我确信你一定在安妮·弗兰克故居看过——一个婚礼派对从窗户挥手，她在从窗户挥手。所以，
for for jews to be seen in public but there's this kind of classic ratchet effect you know yeah jewish teachers get dismissed and then counselors and more and more prohibitions get uh get brought accelerated version of what they'd already done germany i suppose completely but one of the most striking things that happens in amsterdam one of the most heroic episodes get brought in. Accelerated version of what they'd already done in Germany, I suppose. Completely. But, one of the most striking things that happens in Amsterdam, one of the most heroic
犹太人出现在公共场合是可能的，但有一种典型的“棘轮效应”，你知道的，犹太教师被解职，然后是议员，越来越多的禁令被出台。我想，这是他们在德国已经做过的事情的加速版。完全是这样。但是，发生在阿姆斯特丹最令人震惊的事情之一，整个城市历史上最英勇的事件之一，
episodes in the entire history of the city, is marked by a statue over there. I'll just point, it's kind of large, I mean, a fat looking gentleman.
由那边的一个雕像标志着。我指一下，它挺大的，我的意思是，一个看起来胖乎乎的绅士。
Yeah, sturdy, I think. Sturdy gentleman, yes. And this is a statue of a docker, a worker, to commemorate the extraordinary thing that happened in February 1941
对，很健壮，我想。健壮的绅士，是的。这是一个码头工人、一个工人的雕像，为了纪念1941年2月发生的一件非凡的事情：
when the unions in Amsterdam staged a general strike. And in part, this was a protest against Dutch citizens in general being moved to Germany to do forced labor. But it was also specifically a protest against what was happening to the Jews so Lou de Jong historian of Amsterdam describes this as the first and only anti pogrom strike in human history right and of course it's it's a strike that is held by people who assume that the authorities will play by rules that have been laid down in Dutch society for many, many decades. But the Nazis are not playing by these rules. And indeed, the structures of
当时阿姆斯特丹的工会举行了大罢工。在某种程度上，这是对一般荷兰公民被送往德国做苦工的抗议；但它也是对犹太人遭遇的具体抗议。因此，阿姆斯特丹的历史学家卢·德容（Lou de Jong）将此描述为人类历史上第一次也是唯一一次反大屠杀（反迫害）罢工。没错。当然，这是一场由这样一群人发起的罢工：他们假设当局会按照在荷兰社会中制定了数十年的规则行事。但纳粹并没有按这些规则行事。事实上，
bureaucracy are there to be exploited, not to be followed. Well, because there are lots of people who collaborate with the Nazis, though, aren't there? I mean, when Anne Frank is finally, when the Franks are finally shipped off to the camps, it's because of when the Dutch police are involved with that. Yeah. And actually actually Jews in Amsterdam also become complicit. You know, they're kind of forced into this awful situation. It's a bit like in the two episodes we did with Jonathan Friedland. Yeah. Jews in positions of authority are trying to negotiate with the Nazis,
官僚机构的结构是用来被利用的，而不是用来被遵循的。嗯，因为有很多人与纳粹合作，不是吗？我的意思是，当安妮·弗兰克最终——当弗兰克一家最终被运往集中营时，是因为荷兰警察参与其中。是的。而且实际上，阿姆斯特丹的犹太人也变得同谋了。你知道，他们被逼入了这种可怕的境地。这有点像我们和乔纳森·弗里德兰（Jonathan Friedland）一起做的两期节目。是的。处于权力和权威位置的犹太人试图与纳粹谈判，
but are basically being kind of drawn to collaborate. And because the Nazis have access to all these files, these addresses, the identity cards, it's incredibly difficult for Jews to escape. And so hence Anne Frank hiding in the attic. But the fact is that of all the countries occupied by the Nazis, the Jews in the Netherlands had the lowest survival rate. So three out of four Jews who are living in the Netherlands, Jewish, Dutch men and women and children die. Then they're taken to the camps.
但基本上被一步步拖入合作。而且因为纳粹拥有所有这些档案、这些地址和身份证，犹太人想要逃跑难如登天。因此，安妮·弗兰克才会躲在阁楼里。但事实是，在被纳粹占领的所有国家中，荷兰犹太人的生还率是最低的。因此，生活在荷兰的犹太人中，四分之三——犹太裔的荷兰男人、女人和儿童——都死了。然后他们被带到了集中营。
So that population of 80,000, 58,000 are killed. Right. And obviously the scale of the human tragedy, which has been so profoundly articulated by the survival of Anne Frank's diary gives a human face to it. So the horror of, of, of what happens to the Jews is personalized in Amsterdam in a way that perhaps it isn't in any other city occupied by the Nazis. I don't know whether you'd agree. I would agree with that. Yeah. But I think on top of that, what gives it an extra dimension of horror is that basically
所以那8万人口中，有5万8千人被杀害。没错。显然，这场人类悲剧的规模——安妮·弗兰克日记的幸存极其深刻地表达了这一点——赋予了它一个鲜活的人性面孔。因此，犹太人遭遇的恐怖在阿姆斯特丹得到了具象化，这种方式可能是纳粹占领的任何其他城市所没有的。我不知道你是否同意。我同意这一点。是的。但我认为最重要的是，让它增添了一层额外恐怖色彩的是，基本上，
Nazism is pretty much the opposite of everything we've been describing that characterizes the civilization of amsterdam in the modern period internationalist liberal tolerance let live kind of approach yeah which the nazis are having none with and for amsterdam what sets the final seal on the horrors of the war years is that in the winter of 1944 and 45, when the rest of Europe in the West, so France and Belgium and so on, have been liberated, Holland isn't liberated. It's a bridge too far, the failure of the Battle of Arnhem. And that winter is unbelievably terrible. So the Dutch remember it as the honger winter. The honger winter.
纳粹主义几乎是我们一直在描述的、以现代时期阿姆斯特丹文明为特征的一切事物的反面：国际主义、自由宽容、“各得其所”的生活方式——是的，纳粹对此根本不屑一顾。对于阿姆斯特丹来说，给战争岁月的恐怖画上最后句号的是：在1944年和1945年的冬天，当西方其余的欧洲地区——比如法国、比利时等等——已经获得解放时，荷兰却没有被解放。由于阿纳姆战役的失败，这是“遥不可及的一座桥”（A Bridge Too Far）。那个冬天冷酷得难以置信。所以荷兰人将其铭记为“饥饿之冬”（honger winter）。“饥饿之冬”。
And we're sitting outside a flower shop and the Dutch are famous for their gardens. And many people in Amsterdam were reduced to subsistence on the kind of bulbs. Yeah, it's a pretty grim story. The scale of the famine was terrible. And so coming out of the war, I think the impact of the war on the city that Amsterdam becomes in the post-war period, they choose Amsterdam for that. I think that the character of the city, the liberal city,
我们正坐在一家花店外面，而荷兰人以他们的花园闻名。阿姆斯特丹的许多人被迫只能靠吃各种球茎植物来维持勉强糊口的生活。是的，这是一个相当严峻的故事。饥荒的规模太可怕了。因此，经历了战争之后，我认为战争对这座城市的影响——在战后的阿姆斯特丹，他们为此选择了阿姆斯特丹——我认为这座城市的性格，这座自由之城，
is massively, massively informed by the horrors of what happened in the war. Well, before we get on to the liberal city, I'll just say we will definitely return to the story of Anne Frank because I think it's such a heartbreaking story, both in itself, but also as a way into discussing the experience of the Jewish population of the Netherlands and indeed of Europe in the Second World War. So I'm sure we'll return to that
在极大程度上受到了战争中所发生的可怖事件的影响。嗯，在我们继续谈论自由之城前，我只想说，我们肯定会回到安妮·弗兰克的故事上来，因为我认为这是一个如此令人心碎的故事，无论是就其本身而言，还是作为探讨荷兰乃至整个欧洲在二战中犹太人经历的一个切入点。所以我确信我们会再次回到这个话题，
at a future point. But I know, Tom, you're very keen to end the episode by talking about Amsterdam's transformation into the most liberal city, arguably in the world, the crucible of kind of 60s liberalism. And so now we will retrace our steps
在未来的某个时刻。但我知道，汤姆，你非常渴望以讨论阿姆斯特丹转变为可以说是世界上最自由的城市来结束这期节目——这是60年代自由主义的熔炉。所以现在我们将沿着原路返回，
back towards the old heart of the heart of the city and uh tom holland will be venturing into the red light district so let's go let's go so tom we've now walked back from the portuguese synagogue into the the old heart of the city so we're the place where amsterdam was founded and i think it's fair to say this is not the part of the city that i would choose to come on a family friendly break and yet i mean as you say deeply historic so the udekirche the the oldest church in the in the city is just around the corner yes and the street names many of them are redolent of medieval catholic piety yeah so we're just standing next to uh grau monik and kluster the cloister of the gray monks that's your lovely dutch again thank you um but the reason that you wouldn't uh
朝向城市的老中心走去，而汤姆·霍兰将冒险深入红灯区。我们走吧，我们走吧！好了，汤姆，我们现在从葡萄牙犹太会堂步行回到了城市的老中心，也就是阿姆斯特丹的发源地。我觉得可以说，这不是那种我会选择带家人来度个假放松的城市部分，然而，正如你所说，这里有着深厚的历史底蕴。老教堂（Oude Kerk）——城里最古老的教堂，就在转角处。是的，许多街道的名字都带有中世纪天主教虔诚的色彩。是的，我们正站在“Graauwen Monniken Cloister”（灰修士修道院）旁边——又展现了你那优美的荷兰语，谢谢。嗯，但是你不会带人
bring people on a family holiday is that this is the epicenter of the the kind of the liberal dutch attitudes to prostitution and to drugs. Yeah. For which Amsterdam is probably, it's probably the most famous thing about Amsterdam. It is, exactly. More famous than Rembrandt, more famous than the canals. When you say you're going to Amsterdam. More famous than the glories of 17th century culture.
来这里进行家庭度假的原因是，这里是荷兰对待卖淫和毒品等自由主义态度的震中。是的。这也是阿姆斯特丹最著名的方面。确实如此。比伦勃朗更出名，比运河更出名。当你告诉别人你要去阿姆斯特丹时……比17世纪文化的辉煌更出名。
This is what people think of. And I just want to make it absolutely clear for the listeners. I suggested that we walk to look at some more merchant's houses. But Tom said, no, let's record the next bit opposite a massive neon sign saying, sex pass. So when I was in the Brexit passport queue yesterday and the guy behind the counter saw I was British and asked me in very suspicious tones what I was doing here,
这就是人们想到的。我只想对听众澄清一件事。我曾建议我们去散步看一些别的商人宅邸。但汤姆说，不，我们把下一段录音放在一个巨大的霓虹灯招牌对面，上面写着“Sex Palace”（性宫）。昨天我在脱欧护照排队处时，柜台后面的家伙看到我是英国人，用非常怀疑的语气问我来这里做什么，
because I think that so many British tourists come here on stag do's, that there's a kind of move by the Dutch authorities. Tom, don't say this the wrong way, but you're a trifle old for a stag do. Well, I said I'm here due to my love of 17th century Dutch culture. He waved me through. But Dominic, the reason that I wanted to bring you here, particularly, you know, coming off the horrors
因为我想有太多的英国游客来这里进行单身派对（stag do），以至于荷兰当局有一种行动倾向。汤姆，别把这话听岔了，但对于单身派对来说，你稍微老了一点。好吧，我说我来这里是因为我热爱17世纪的荷兰文化。他挥手让我通过了。但是，多米尼克，我想把你带到这里的原因——特别是考虑到我们在葡萄牙犹太会堂讨论过的那些恐怖经历——是因为我认为绝对有理由认为，这种对性和毒品乃至移民问题持超自由主义态度的现象，绝对是阿姆斯特丹在战争中经历的创伤的反映。但我认为你也可以争辩说，20世纪60年代自由主义的根源及其后续影响可以追溯得更远。因为在整个这两期节目中，我们一直在讨论阿姆斯特丹这种独特的态度，
that we were discussing by the Portuguese synagogue, is that I think that there is absolutely a case to be made that this kind of hyper-liberalism in attitudes towards sex and drugs and indeed to immigration is absolutely a reflection of the trauma that Amsterdam went through in the war. But I think you could also argue that the roots of 1960s liberalism and the aftermath of that go back even further. Because throughout these two episodes, we've been talking about this distinctive attitude in amsterdam yeah whereby things are allowed to operate on the kind of the margins of the legal and the illegal yeah so we've been talking about you know catholics and calvinist amsterdam
即允许某些事物在合法与非法的边缘运作——是的，所以我们一直在谈论天主教徒和加尔文主义的阿姆斯特丹、各种各样的宗教少数群体。在某种程度上，红灯区对待性和毒品的态度就是这种态度的遗留。所以这个地方——你非常客气地带我来的“性宫”——与贝居安会院（Beguinhof）——那个带有救济院的美丽庭院——之间存在着一种连续性，
various assorted religious minorities and in a way the attitudes to kind of the sex and drugs here in the red light district is a kind of legacy of that so there's a continuity between this place the sex palace that you very kindly brought me to and the beguine hoff the beautiful kind of courtyard yeah with the almshouses yeah because it's basically we're going to turn a blind you know the thing about turning a blind eye to to ensure civic unity yeah i mean you would think that the Begainhof, a place devoted to, you know, charity and sexual continence and a sex palace, there could be no greater contrast. But actually, I think they are expressions of something that is a kind of continuity in the
因为这基本上就是“睁一只眼闭一只眼”……你知道，为了确保公民团结而对某些事睁一只眼闭一只眼。是的，我的意思是，你可能会认为贝居安会院——一个致力于慈善和性节制的地方——和一个“性宫”之间不会有比这更大的反差了。但实际上，我认为它们都是某种根植于公民文化的连续性的表现形式。但我确实认为这明确体现了一种决心，即彻底否定纳粹主义的遗产。好吧，所以在二战后几乎立即出现的对同性恋权利的激进态度中，你可以非常清楚地看到这一点。所以在1946年，
civic culture. But I do think it is specifically a kind of determination to repudiate the legacy of Nazism okay so you see this very clearly in the kind of the radical approach to gay rights which emerges almost immediately after the war so in 1946 um it's in amsterdam that you get the world's first organization to advance gay rights um 1964 the chairman of that organization goes on national tv and is the first kind of openly gay person to appear on dutch tv right and you know the 60s across the world there's a kind of cascade effect of of liberalization but in the netherlands it's very very radical to the degree that in 2000 the netherlands becomes the first country in the world to legalize same-sex yeah which i can
正是在阿姆斯特丹，诞生了世界上第一个促进同性恋权利的组织。1964年，该组织的负责人登上国家电视台，成为第一个在荷兰电视上公开露面的同性恋者。而且你知道，60年代世界各地都涌现出一股自由化浪潮，但在荷兰，它是非常非常激进的，以至于在2000年，荷兰成为世界上第一个将同性婚姻合法化的国家——这我还能记得。我的意思是，我记得当时这件事发生时，国际媒体的报道中有一种感觉，认为这是一种奇怪的荷兰反常现象。但当然，正如在许多战后事务中一样，荷兰人正在开辟一条道路。因此，正如在17世纪一样，在20世纪和21世纪，阿姆斯特丹依然是一座为世界其余地区定下基调的城市。所以我想你也可以在对移民的高度自由主义态度中，非常清楚地看到对纳粹主义恐怖的反弹。没错。所以同样地，从70年代开始，越来越多的移民涌入阿姆斯特丹，正如整个荷兰一样，臭名昭著的咖啡馆（coffee shops）——嗯，臭名昭著还是闻名遐迩，取决于你的
remember i mean remember at the time when that happened there was a sense in the reporting in the world to legalize same-sex marriage. Yeah, which I can remember. I mean, I remember at the time when that happened, there was a sense in the reporting in the international press that this was a sort of outlandish Dutch anomaly. But of course, the Dutch, as in so many of these post-war things, blazing a trail. So as in the 17th century, so in the 20th and 21st century, Amsterdam remains a city that is kind of setting the beat for the rest of the world. So I think you can also see very clearly a reaction to the horrors of Nazism in the kind of very liberal attitude to immigration. Right. So again, from the seventies onwards, increasing immigration to Amsterdam as indeed across the Netherlands, the notorious coffee, well, notorious or famous, depending on your
态度——出售大麻的咖啡馆，有点像17世纪阿姆斯特丹的天主教小礼拜堂。是的，大麻并不合法，但如果它在私营场所出售，就不会被禁止。换句话说，你不能在街上卖它，但你可以在“咖啡馆”里卖它，也就是他们所称的“coffee shops”。是的，是的。所以这又是你的“贝居安会院”平行对照，对吧？是的，在闭门之后。是的。所以荷兰人率先提出了隐私的概念。因此，私人行为与公共道德之间存在着一种独特的、持续的区别。是的，是的。我想，这或许终极的讽刺就是那些在玻璃窗后展示自己的女性。这是一种绝对的讽刺，关于荷兰房屋的那种理念——房屋的隐私，以及隐私与公众之间的界面。我认为另一件非常“荷兰”、非常“阿姆斯特丹”的事情是，性工作在阿姆斯特丹的组织方式是：这里的女性不仅把自己塑造为女权主义者（因此她们称自己为性工作者而不是妓女），而且她们也为自己作为工会成员而感到自豪。
attitude, the coffee shops marijuana kind of like catholic chapels in 17th century um amsterdam yeah marijuana isn't legal but it's not banned if it's sold in private establishments so in other words you can't sell it on the streets but you can sell it in coffee shops coffee shops as they call them yeah yeah so this is your beguine half parallel again right yes behind closed doors yes so the dutch who pioneered the idea of privacy yeah so there's a distinct a continuing distinction between private behavior and kind of public morality yes yes and i guess the kind of the the ultimate parody perhaps of that is the women who advertise themselves behind glass windows it's a kind of absolute parody of that kind of that is the women who advertise themselves behind glass windows. It's a kind of
所以在80年代，曾有一个名为“红线”（The Red Thread）的组织，这是一个倡导团体。许多人加入了工会。避孕套可以抵税。所有这一切，我的意思是，这非常非常阿姆斯特丹。我不知道你有没有看过哈里和保罗（Harry and Paul，即哈里·恩菲尔德 Harry Enfield 和保罗·怀特豪斯 Paul Whitehouse）的节目，他们对这一点有一种精彩的演绎。我认为这就是国外对阿姆斯特丹的印象。
absolute parody of that kind of idea of the Dutch house, the privacy of the house and the kind of interface between the privacy and the public. And the other thing that I think is again, very kind of Dutch, very Amsterdam about the way that, um, sex work is organized in Amsterdam is that the women here are casting themselves not just as feminists, so hence they would call themselves sex workers rather than prostitutes, but they are also very proud of themselves as members of unions.
那是阿姆斯特丹警察局的斯特凡·范·德·哈特格拉赫特队长（Captain Stefan van der Hathgracht），由保罗·怀特豪斯扮演，你知道的，他们手铐纯粹是为了性爱游戏……好吧，汤姆，我们面临着你把整个喜剧小品演一遍的危险，但我觉得它很好地总结了阿姆斯特丹作为一个“百无禁忌”之地的观念——这绝对是英国人的看法。我的意思是，这里距离英国显然只有短短的一程，这就是为什么它是如此巨大的单身派对目的地。人们来这里是因为他们认为阿姆斯特丹——具有讽刺意味的是，一个加尔文主义的地方，一个崇尚隐私、温文尔雅的地方（好吧，也许不是温文尔雅，我想是谦逊、得体、自我纪律和所有这些东西的地方）——但在今天的英国，它被视为一个享乐主义的天堂。绝对是这样。而且我认为，
So in the 80s, there was a kind of an organization called the Red Thread that was an advocacy group. Lots belong to trade unions. Condoms are tax deductible. All this kind of, I mean, it's very, very Amsterdam. I don't know if you saw Harry and Paul, the Harry Enfield and Paul Whitehouse, and they have a brilliant kind of evocation of this. I think this idea of what Amsterdam is like abroad.
我的意思是，我认为同样地，我们在阿姆斯特丹历史上一直在探讨的这些紧张关系依然存在：你会看到玻璃窗后赤身裸体展示自己的女性，而如果你在不该吸烟的公共场所吸烟，她们会出来训斥你……对吧，汤姆，你验证过这一点吗？我没有，但是……法律就是用来遵守的，如果你在阿姆斯特丹乱穿马路，你就会惹上麻烦。就是那种……法律仍然存在，它并不是一个“享乐主义、百无禁忌”的地方。我认为另一件充分体现荷兰当局希望收紧对来这里的游客和单身派对等活动的控制的事，是人们感觉到：
It's Captain Stefan van der Hathgracht of the amsterdam police and it's a poor white house and it's you know it's they have handcuffs purely for sex games and uh right we're in danger of you doing the entire sketch now tom but i think it kind of sums up an idea of amsterdam as anything goes kind of place which is the perception certainly in britain i mean it's obviously just a short hop from britain and that's why it's such a massive stag do destination is people go because they think of amsterdam ironically a calvinist place the place of privacy and gentility well not gentility i suppose but modesty and decorum and and self-discipline and all these things but in britain today it is perceived as this hedonistic paradise absolutely and i i think
阿姆斯特丹的自由主义已经被推向了极限，以至于连世界上最自由的城市实际上也并不喜欢它的终点。因为在一个普遍尚未将卖淫和毒品合法化的世界里，将它们合法化的一大后果是，它使得咖啡馆或红灯区成为犯罪卡特尔的掩护。我正想说，我的意思是，这个地区绝对有一种藏污纳垢、藏垢纳污的感觉。完全是这样——我的意思是，你知道的，总会有这样一个灰色地带，让你不知不觉滑入有组织犯罪的世界。我的意思是，我认为这不仅仅是藏污纳垢，我认为外国犯罪团伙一直利用荷兰、当然还有阿姆斯特丹作为妇女走私和大量毒品进口的中心。这就是为什么这里的当局试图收回早期那种头脑发热的自由主义。所以这就是当把自由主义推向极致时，21世纪紧张局势的完美例证。是的。我认为其中最敏感的表达是在移民维度上以及荷兰自由主义与伊斯兰教的关系上，因为来到阿姆斯特丹的许多移民都是穆斯林，这显然是远溯至宗教改革时期的传统的一部分。这是一个单身派对（hen do），汤姆。我想某个聚会人群出现了。因此，在大屠杀之后，显然有一种绝对的决心，绝不以任何方式暗示荷兰自由主义框架与伊斯兰教之间可能存在紧张关系。然后突然间，也许在9·11事件之后，情况发生了逆转，因为荷兰文化的另一个表达是言论自由的传统。所以，早在邻国发生之前，你就已经有了很多从自由主义角度直言不讳的人。比如皮姆·富图恩（Pim van Tuijn），他是一位同性恋权利活动家，他说：“我不是反穆斯林。我和很多穆斯林上床。我只是不喜欢伊斯兰教。”
i mean i think again there is the these kind of tensions that we've been exploring throughout the history of amsterdam that you have uh you know women behind glass windows advertising themselves naked and they will you know if you're smoking in public where you shouldn't they'll come out and scold you um right so have you put that to the test tom i haven't but but the you know the laws are there to be obeyed and you know if you get if you jaywalk in amsterdam you get in trouble it's that kind of it's that kind of the laws are still there it's not a kind of hedonist anything anything goes place and i think the other thing so expressive of this desire on the part of the dutch authorities to to rein back on tourists coming here, snag parties and things, is the sense that liberalism
他被暗杀了——不是被穆斯林暗杀的，我想是一个动物权利抗议者干的。但随后在这里的阿姆斯特丹，众所周知，另一位对伊斯兰教抱有敌意的领军自由主义人物被谋杀，甚至险些被斩首。那就是西奥·范·高克（Theo van Gogh），他是文森特·范·高克的后代。他拍摄了一部名为《臣服》（Submission）的电影，
in Amsterdam has been pushed to limits that even the most liberal city in the world doesn't actually like the end point. Because one of the things about legalizing prostitution and drugs in a world where generally they haven't been legalized is that it enables say the coffee shops or the um the red light district to become the front for criminal cartels i was about to say i mean there's a definite sense of uh of seediness frank of sleaziness about this area to be completely well i mean you know and a sense in which there's always a a gray area where you're sliding into the world of organized crime i mean i think it's more than seediness i think that you know it's foreign criminal gangs have used the
合作者是一位名叫阿扬·希尔西·阿里（Ayaan Hirsi Ali）的女性，她是一名索马里人，曾来到这里，在某种程度上变成了一个年轻的穆斯林女性在祈祷，全身包裹在穆斯林长袍中，除了身体中间暴露在外，上面写满了古兰经的经文。当她祈祷时，背景音中传来各种穆斯林女性的声音，讲述她们如何认为古兰经和古兰经法助长了对她们的压迫。这犹如一颗炸弹落地。所以我想，自由主义的准则与伊斯兰教之间的那种紧张关系，
netherlands and certainly amsterdam as centers for kind of mass trafficking of women, mass import of drugs. And that's why the authorities here are trying to kind of rein back on the kind of the giddy liberalism of an earlier age. So there you have the perfect example of the 21st century tensions when you push liberalism to its ultimate extreme. Yes. And I think the most sensitive expression of that is in the dimension of immigration and on the relationship of Dutch liberalism to Islam, because many of the immigrants who've come to Amsterdam are Muslim, and that is obviously part of a tradition that goes right the way back to the Reformation. It's a hen do, Tom. I think some party has turned up. So in the wake of the Holocaust, there was obviously an absolute determination not to in any way imply that there might be a tension between the frameworks of Dutch
对种族主义和反种族主义的焦虑——那种在过去几十年里，包括英国、美国、法国和德国在内的其他国家的人们一直试图解开的结——正是在阿姆斯特丹，这种紧张关系首次得到了真正的激化。而且人们普遍有一种感觉，在阿姆斯特丹——如果我错了请纠正我——那就是城市当局已经从20世纪60年代以来的极度自由主义中稍微回过头来了。我想是的。2023年人们感到的焦虑，可能比1960年代以来的任何时候都要多，关于红灯区、关于毒品、
liberalism and Islam. And then suddenly, maybe in the wake of 9-11, that flipped because another expression of Dutch culture is the tradition of free speech. And so you have, long before it happened in neighboring countries, you had very outspoken people talking from a kind of liberal perspective. So Pim van Tuijn, who was a gay rights campaigner, said, I'm not anti-Muslim. I sleep with lots of Muslims. I just don't like Islam.
关于移民、关于所有这些事情的焦虑，而且阿姆斯特丹再次可以说是整个西方世界正在发生的事情的一个范例——转向反对人们视为极端的极度自由主义。是的。而且我认为，至少自17世纪以来在这座城市中表现出来的自由主义、宽容、全球化和超级资本主义的传统，仍然是完全活生生的传统。这就是为什么发生在阿姆斯特丹的事情会在全世界引起共鸣。这里充满了运河，美得不可思议，但它不是威尼斯。它不是一件博物馆展品。这是一座在欧洲乃至世界思考方式上仍然具有巨大影响力的城市。我认为，正是这一点使
And he got assassinated, not by a Muslim, by, I think it was by an animal rights protester. But then here in Amsterdam, notoriously, another leading liberal figure who was hostile to Islam was murdered and indeed almost decapitated. And that was Theo van Gogh, who was a descendant of Vincent van Gogh. And he made a film called Submission
它成为一个如此不可思议的旅游胜地。你知道，当你来到这里时，你真的不是在参观一座博物馆。所以谢谢你，汤姆。这是一次——我敢说——气势恢宏的全景式精彩游览。噢，你过奖了。这里有真正的地方感、城市感，以及它作为欧洲乃至世界历史上诸多发展缩影的这种方式。现在，对我们的听众来说有个好消息，汤姆，
with a woman called Ayaan Hirsi Ali, who was a Somali who'd come here and in a way become a young Muslim woman praying, dressed head to toe in Muslim robes, except that the middle of her body is exposed and it's covered with verses from the Quran. And as she prays, voiceovers are heard of various Muslim women talking about how they say that the Quran and Quranic law has facilitated their oppression. And this was landed as an explosion. So I think that that kind of tension between the dictates of liberalism and Islam,
那就是WISE制作了一份阿姆斯特丹的旅行指南，其中包含了你今天节目中谈到的许多地点——尽管可能没有“性宫”……没有性宫，听到这里他们会松一口气。因此，要了解更多关于如何像历史学家一样旅行——你可以像历史学家汤姆·霍兰一样旅行，同时又能像当地人一样消费——你可以像荷兰男人或荷兰女人一样花钱。请访问wise.com/restishistory，或者点击今天节目简介中的链接。带着这个好消息，汤姆，我们要说非常感谢。汤姆，你可以自由去享受阿姆斯特丹的乐趣了。非常感谢。
the anxieties about racism and anti-racism, that kind of knot, which has been one that people in other countries, including Britain, including America, including France, including Germany, have been trying to unpick over the past couple of decades it was in amsterdam that that was kind of first really stressed and there's a sense in amsterdam generally correct me if i'm wrong but that the the city authorities have slightly turned away from the ultra liberalism from the 1960s onwards i think so there's much more anxiety now in 2023 than at probably any point since the 1960s about you know the red light district about drugs about
我要回家了。伴随着这个重磅消息，再见，再见！本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
immigration about all these kind of things and amsterdam again is you could argue a paradigm for what's happening in the western world more generally a turn against what people see as the extremes of kind of hyper liberalism yeah and. And I think that the traditions of liberalism, of tolerance, of globalization, of hyper-capitalism that have been manifest in this city since at least the 17th century are still completely living traditions. And that is why what happens in Amsterdam reverberates across the world. It's full of canals and it's incredibly beautiful, but it's not Venice. It's not a museum piece. This is a city that is still massively influential in the way that Europe and indeed the world thinks. And I think that that is what makes
关于移民等各种问题，阿姆斯特丹再次可以说是西方世界正在发生的事情的一个范例，人们开始转向反对他们所认为的极端超自由主义。我认为，自至少17世纪以来一直在该市体现的自由主义、宽容、全球化和超级资本主义的传统，至今仍然是完全活生生的传统。这就是为什么阿姆斯特丹发生的事情会在全世界引起共鸣。它到处都是运河，美得不可思议，但它不是威尼斯。它不是一件博物馆藏品。这座城市对欧洲乃至全世界的思考方式仍然具有巨大的影响力。我认为正是这一点使得
it such an incredible place to visit. You know, you really are not visiting a museum when you come here. So thank you, Tom. That was, dare I say, a panoramic tour de force. Oh, you're too kind. A real sense of place, sense of the city, and sense of the way in which it has served as this kind of microcosm of so many developments in European and indeed world history. Now, the good news for our listeners, Tom,
它成为一个令人难以置信的旅游胜地。你知道，当你来到这里时，你真的不是在参观一座博物馆。所以谢谢你，汤姆。这是一次，我敢说，全景式的精彩讲解。哦，你过奖了。对这个地方有着真实的感受，对这座城市有着真实的感受，并且感受到它作为欧洲乃至世界历史上如此多的发展的一个缩影的方式。现在，对我们的听众来说好消息是，汤姆，
is that WISE have created a travel guide to amsterdam that includes many of the locations that you've talked about in today's episode although possibly not the uh the sex palace that we're not the sex palace they'll be they'll be very relieved to hear so to learn more about how you can travel like a historian you can travel like historian tom holland and yet still spend like a local you can spend spend like a Dutchman or Dutch woman. Visit wise.com slash restishistory or click the link in today's description. And on that note, Tom, we say thank you very much. Tom, you're free to go and enjoy the delights of Amsterdam. Thank you very much.
WISE制作了一份阿姆斯特丹旅游指南，其中包含了你在今天的节目中谈到的许多地点，虽然可能不包括那个嗯色情宫殿，不包括色情宫殿，他们听到这个会感到非常庆幸。因此，要了解更多关于如何像历史学家一样旅行，你可以像历史学家汤姆·霍兰一样旅行，但仍然像当地人一样消费，你可以像荷兰男人或荷兰女人一样消费。访问 wise.com/restishistory 或点击今天简介中的链接。带着这句话，汤姆，我们要非常感谢你。汤姆，你可以自由去享受阿姆斯特丹的乐趣了。非常感谢。
I'm going home. And on that bombshell goodbye goodbye There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我要回家了。带着这个重磅消息，再见，再见。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。